today i'm going to show you the limitations of
lots why power grades are revolutionary compared
to them and how to use davinci resolve to create
your own lots no matter if you're using premiere
pro final cut as your main editing software to
showcase the limitations of lots in general i have
here a test slot which i will apply on the footage
looks pretty good but the yellows look super
desaturated so let's try to bring back the yellows
and here comes a problem when i try to bring back
the yellows i notice very little is changing and
that is because the lot desaturated the yellows
to a point of no return so the information is gone
after you applied a lot to a clip you're actually
working against it and you're losing control over
the image luts in general are okay but are very
limiting and can hold only so much information to
be more exact only hue saturation and luma values
so they are very limited in what they can
reproduce from a more complex color grade
also you cannot go inside the grade and adjust it
to your liking which means normally you have to
work against a lot and can result in colors
falling apart and frustrating experiences
that is because each editing software has
its own language so they had to create a
universal standard a file that worked for
each that's why when i apply this slot
and try to recover information it's a useless and
frustrating battle with no happy endings power
grades on the other hand will offer you full
control and transparency over the adjustments
and finally they can be exported
as lots for any other software
so basically you can just use premiere final cut
as your main editing software and use davinci
as your lot creator and i'll show you how we'll
start with how to import power grades into davinci
resolve how to organize them into folders and
finally how to use them to create your own lots
so as an example for this tutorial i will import
my creative film power grades which contains 35
film contrast 55 classic film colors together
with the beloved resolution effects as you can
see i already created a couple clips with these
power grades and they look really really good
first in the color tab left corner make a couple
power grade albums by pressing right click and
choose add power grade album make four of them and
rename them by double clicking on the album name
first will be the note 3 second film contrast
third film color and the last will be the halation
you can find the power grade on my website link
in description down below go into each folder and
start importing the creative film pack one by one
by pressing right click and import with output lut
now that we have everything imported
and organized let me show you how to
use the creative film powergrade and how
you can make your own custom film luts
you can start by either adding your own nodes
pressing alt s on windows or command s on mac
or by using my custom node tree to save you
some time i'll use the already imported node
tree to make it easier let's add a contrast and
exposure to establish the base look of the footage
so you can understand exactly what i'm doing nodes
are pretty much just like layers in photoshop
and they work sequential meaning the last node
always will have power over the rest so if i add
a final node and lower down the saturation it will
affect all the other nodes this is a quick tip
you can enroll in my online classes if you want
to learn more tips about color grading in a short
period of time link in description so first we set
a contrast and exposure to see what we are working
with scrub to all the film contrast to see exactly
how it will affect the image and then choose your
favorite to apply it just drag and drop on top of
the node we can go in the curve tab and adjust it
to your liking you're gonna do this with regular
luts which is a huge advantage if you don't like
the one chosen and you want different film
contrast hit control z on windows or command
z on mac to reset the node to a previous version
then just choose a new film contrast and apply it
remember you must activate
the splines to edit the curve
next we scroll through the classic film color
album and check a couple to see which one would
best fit our footage again you just have
to drag and drop on top of the desired node
i'll just apply a couple to see how it
affects image until i find one that i like
to switch between the film colors faster i just
drag and drop the film color then hit ctrl z to
reset the note 3 to previous versions and apply
a new film color from here you either leave it as
it is or you can dive deeper into the settings and
adjust different values i have a node explanation
sheet contained in the product folder so you know
exactly how each node affects the image and where
are the adjustments located as you can see there
are some really great color palettes in this
collection and it's making my life so much easier
from here you can either leave it as it is or
you can dive deeper into the settings and adjust
different values in the film color node you can go
into different curves tabs and adjust the colors
on your taste for example in this shot i feel like
the reds are too saturated so i will just go into
huber's saturation and bring it down just a notch
so this is much faster and easier than
starting from scratch with a regular grade
and you have full control compared to a classical
lot if you're using davinci you can play around
with inhalation settings and you're pretty much
done if you're a premiere or final cut user
follow the next steps to export the lot right
click on the clip and choose generate lut remember
lust contain only three values hue saturation
and luma so any davinci resolve plug-in effects
won't be contained by the lut so let's
disable the collision and the film grain
let's make a 65 point q blot to ensure colors
will not fall apart choose the destination folder
and export and now you can create as many luts as
you want without even having to learn color theory
you can also create black and white lots just
bring down the saturation to zero and apply your
favorite film contrast this is how you can easily
create your own lots using the creative film power
grade for davinci resolve there's a link to
the power grade in the description down below
the cool part about this power grade is
compatible with the rest of my product
let's say we have a super 8 mm home film
power grade you haven't seen the video
i'll put a link in the upright corner
for you to watch later all you have to
do is just choose a clip and double click
to apply the power grade it's that easy
let's adjust the contrast to match the footage
and here you can see multiple nodes all our
names so it's easier to find and know what you're
working with these power grades were made to work
with any kind of footage log rec709 10-bit or even
8-bit it's finely tuned so colors won't fall apart
this power grade pack comes in 10 flavors and
has really vibrant and nostalgic kind of colors
but even though you have 10 different flavors
maybe you get bored and just want something new
so you can borrow a color palette from the
creative film power grades and create something
completely new go back to the classic film color
album and just drag one of the color schemes onto
the film color node and now you have a totally
different look and this applies with all my power
grades the 35 read and film the 8 millimeter
home film and the vhs camcorder emulation
which is a huge value if you think about it so
what i'm trying to do with these power grades
is give you great color out of the box but also
give you full control over how the image should
look like and also enable you to be more creative
combining 35 contrast gammas together with over 50
classic film colors your possibilities are pretty
much limitless and can easily get over 1000 unique
lot variations and that without even entering the
notes and modifying them so you can find all these
power grades on my website the major problem with
using luts they sometimes don't work well with
our footage because it was shot in different
scenarios with different lightings and colors
so if the footage is a little bit overexposed or
has different colors then you just start working
against a lot to match it with the rest of the
footage and end up spending more time repairing
something that could have been only a couple of
minutes because luts are destructive while power
grades are not now you can take control of your
image by creating your own custom lots easily
without any compromises with power grades you can
easily edit with full control you can actually
learn about color theory just by going inside
each node and experimenting with a good base
finally if you don't want to use davinci you
just export the desired look as lots and you
can use them in premiere pro final cut or any
other editing software but davinci is free
and has great color grading features and the
experience is much nicer if you want to find out
more about color grading i invite you to my online
course which will help you easily understand color
grading in a short period of time in this course i
will guide you in the process of creating your own
footage and explain different techniques that will
make the whole process easier to grasp all the
lots will be provided at the end of the course for
free so go check it out save your spot is going
to be fun link in description so that's it for
today hope this helped clear out some questions
let me know in the comments what you like to see
next until then have fun and stay curious see ya
you